june 27 2017 alex smith a 26 year old
restaurant manager in minnesota is found
dead in his apartment he died alone
scared and helpless
you see at 23 years old alec was
diagnosed with type 1 diabetes the
diagnosis was a shock but at least he
could still get his life-saving medicine
insulin on his mom's insurance but then
he turned 26 and according to the
insurance policy he was now on his own
he couldn't be covered under his mom's
insurance anymore he tried to get
insurance for himself but it would cost
440 a month and before he was even
covered he would have to pay 7 600
out of his own pocket for the medicine
he needed to survive
he couldn't afford any of that so he
rolled the dice and resorted to buying
the insulin with cash he was trying to
save up to afford insurance but as a
restaurant manager that was next to
impossible
one vial of insulin costs around 285
dollars and most diabetics need two to
four vials a month that is more than one
thousand dollars a month for a drug
meant to keep him alive so when alex
money ran out he had to start rationing
his medication to make it last longer
instead of living paycheck to paycheck
he was living insulin shot to insulin
shots but even his best efforts didn't
make a difference
my son died
because he could not afford his insulin
he died 27 days after losing insurance
the cause of death diabetic ketoacidosis
a direct result of his body not getting
the insulin he desperately needed
but what if i told you all of this was
100 avoidable what if i told you that
one vial of insulin costs just around
five dollars to produce even with all
the added research marketing and sales
fees there's no way a five dollar
commodity magically turns into 250
let's put it this way what do you see
someone gaining access to first world
healthcare someone getting a
prescription for medication that will
keep them alive i'll tell you what i see
i see one thousand dollars per month
just for insulin that's twelve thousand
dollars a year six hundred sixty
thousand dollars in their lifetime if
insulin prices stay the same which they
don't and that's the average some people
need more insulin and end up paying
thousands of dollars more every year
just to stay alive
there are 37 million americans living
with diabetes if just half of them
needed insulin to stay healthy that's
over 220 billion dollars a year in
revenue
but here's the problem insulin doesn't
have to be that expensive that same vial
that costs 250 in america costs around
35 dollars in canada
so what is really going on here how can
a drug cost almost 10 times more in
america than it does for his next door
neighbor
this is the insulin rackets
[Music]
insulin manufacturers have massive teams
of sales people and lawyers to make sure
they can get away with ripping customers
off but it's not just evil corporations
who rely on their employees most great
businesses are made of talented
hard-working people who want the company
to succeed but hiring the perfect
candidate is usually a long and
expensive process you've gotta sort
through hundreds of resumes most of
which aren't the right fits it's like
finding a needle in a haystack that is
where zip recruiter comes in zip
recruiter is an online marketplace it
started out as a way to help small
businesses find employees and it turned
into the number one rated hiring site in
the us today four out of every five
employers who post on ziprecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
did you know it costs an average of four
thousand dollars to hire a new employee
that can add a fast especially if you
end up hiring people who aren't the
right match that's why zip recruiter is
the smartest way to hire because zip
recruiter uses ai to match your
company's jobs with the right candidates
you can easily review and rate zip
recruiters recommended candidates right
on your dashboard and then you can
personally invite your favorite
candidates to apply for the job zip
recruiter actually learns for your
ratings of candidates to send you
similar candidates in the future while
other hiring companies give you way too
many options ziprecruiter helps you find
the needle in the haystack right now you
can try ziprecruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com jaketran that's
j-a-k-e-t-r-a-n that's
ziprecruiter.com to try it out for free
thanks to zip recruiter for sponsoring
this video
back in the early 1900s getting
diagnosed with diabetes was as good as a
death sentence healthy people make their
own insulin people with type 1 diabetes
don't that means their blood sugar would
get high every time they ate and every
meal would leave them at risk of dying
of the same thing alex smith suffered
diabetic ketoacidosis for diabetics 100
years ago there was nothing to do but
wait for the inevitable but then in 1921
a guy named friedrich banting discovered
how to isolate insulin from dogs a few
years later researchers were able to
create insulin injections and the first
dose was effectively given to a 14 year
old boy suddenly people who were dying
of diabetes had hope here was this
miracle drug that could let them live
years longer than ever expected in 1923
the insulin researchers won the nobel
prize and instead of thinking of all the
billions of dollars they could make by
selling it they sold the patent for just
one dollar they wanted everyone to have
access to this new drug that could save
their lives but just a few years later
all their big hopes for insulin would be
crushed
[Music]
what would you do if you could sell
people life what if you knew a cheap
simple drug like insulin could mean the
difference between life and death for
people with diabetes if you were the
manufacturer would you produce this drug
for as low of a price as possible or
take your chance to profit big time
insulin manufacturers chose the latter
so instead of making insulin affordable
the manufacturers got together allegedly
and decided to raise prices as high as
they want in unison at first they said
it was because they were developing
better forms of the drug but then people
realized that the actual insulin being
sold hasn't changed much in over 20
years so then they blamed it on research
on how expensive the manufacturing
process is on how complex the supply
chain has become and all these excuses
let them get away with doubling the
price of insulin almost every five years
because these manufacturers realize one
thing when you're selling the difference
between life and death people will do
everything they can to buy it no matter
the price and as the years went by the
three main manufacturers of insulin in
america just found even more ways to
screw their customers over
only three companies manufacture insulin
in the us cenophy novo nordisk and eli
lilly you would imagine that with three
different manufacturers competition
would push the price of insulin down but
here's the thing for as long as these
companies have been making insulin their
prices have only ever increased and if
that's not suspicious enough every price
increase between the three manufacturers
is usually very similar and around the
same time
every time eli lilly raises its prices
sanofi and novo nordisk follow suits and
if this is starting to sound a little
bit like a cartel to you where companies
band together to control prices and
prevent newcomers from coming in it's
because it probably is
now you might be asking yourself why
doesn't someone else just come in and
sell insulin at a lower price the patent
must have expired it's almost 100 years
old right well that's where you're wrong
again to prevent the pan from ever
expiring these insulin manufacturers
make a few tiny irrelevant changes to
the drug every couple years so they can
keep extending their patent so even if a
company wanted to come in and make
affordable insulin they would probably
get sued for billions of dollars and
here's another problem insulin isn't a
chemical drug it's a biological one so
unlike chemical medications that have a
brand and generic version there is no
generic version of insulin because it's
not the ingredients or recipe being
patented it's the actual insulin itself
that is under pattern
and if you think manufacturers are the
only ones profiting in the scheme you
are sadly mistaken once an insulin vial
has been manufactured it moves from the
manufacturers to the wholesalers and
eventually to the pharmacy at each of
these steps a markup is added to make
everyone in the chain money once the
insulin reaches a pharmacy patients
without insurance have to pay for the
full cost of each vial and those with
insurance think they're getting a better
deal but they're getting just as screwed
as the uninsured with all the middlemen
involved with insurance companies
[Music]
for people who can't afford insulin in
america accessing the medicine they need
to survive means getting a little
creative some travel to canada or mexico
to get their prescriptions filled in
some cases prices are up to 10 times
cheaper and for those who can't afford
to drive or fly to get their medication
staying on their parents health
insurance for as long as possible is
their best chance unfortunately like
alex smith once they turn 26 is not an
option anymore others turn to the
insulin black market to get their hands
on cheaper medication other star
gofundme accounts to cover their monthly
costs it's gotten so bad that some
doctors will even hand over all the free
samples they have to people in need
these samples might not even be the kind
of insulin the patients need but is all
they've got and when that's not
available some people even resort to
using expired or older versions of
insulin hoping it can still keep them
alive all the while manufacturers are
still pushing out prices and no one can
do anything to stop them
[Music]
you